the kardashians are doing quarantine
with the capital k
this is the ultimate fort the famous
family is living that self-isolation
life
and they appear to have the whole thing
figured out she made
a quarantined section for
kim and kanye
over at kim's house it's all about the
kids north
and her houses kim hit up her insta
story to share this cardboard
masterpiece from her six-year-old
daughter north
she made a quarantined section
for kim
and kanye
[Laughter]
and check this out this is the ultimate
for oh
i see you hanging out there kim and
kanye's kiddos built the fort to end
all forts
mommy's coming inside
two-year-old shy delivered your daily
dose of sunshine singing to her baby bro
song
then there was this
yeah that's a live lobster walking down
kim street
kim shared the clip on her insta story
monday asking the question on everyone's
mind
what is happening later kim announced
that kkw
beauty will postpone a product launch
that was scheduled for the end of the
month
and she sent lots of love to her fans
with this puckered up pick
peace begin with me
over at courtney's house it's all about
the zen
i'm doing yoga from peace speaker with
me
and i'm doing the real one court shared
that clip of her five-year-old son rayne
meditating on instagram in the caption
she explained that they've been reading
books
watching movies baking dancing around
the kitchen
playing dress-up and most importantly
really slowing down and spending time
together
the mom of three made waffles with lots
of syrup did a devotional next to the
fire in bed
and she shared this pic of a cake
writing straight from kris jenner's
kitchen
along with some questions about how much
she washed her hands
as for chris a source tells et that the
64 year old
was tested for the flu-like virus and
the results came back negative
quote chris wasn't sick and didn't have
any symptoms but since she was in
contact with someone who tested positive
she took the test on monday chris took
to twitter to thank people working on
the front lines writing
stay kind be safe we are in this
together
kylie's been spending quarantine in the
kitchen making muffins
and matzo ball soup then there's kendall
and chloe who both expressed their
feelings about quarantine on insta
chloe with this pick of her daughter
true alongside the caption
how i feel about 2020 and kendall
would this mean
you